l'enseignante Vicky Vachon ne décolèrent
pas depuis son retour au Québec lors de
son voyage à Cayo Coco avec des amis
elle aurait rencontré un ingénieur
prénommé Simon au bar de l'hôtel le 3
juillet
me prie la fesse d'une façon
très très intense très agressive et une
très grosse poignée de fesses et
évidemment je me suis fâchée je lui
roulais dessus je lui ai donné un bon
coup de pied sur les tibia et là il
disait je suis désolé je suis désolé
c'est mes mains c'est pas moi c'est mes
mains c'est mes mains c'est à son retour
dans les Laurentides que Vicky Vachon
aurait vu Simon hall dans les médias il
l'aurait immédiatement reconnu j'ai eu
un choc
ça me troublé au plus haut point un
autre touriste qui ne voyageait pas avec
elle affirme aussi avoir identifié
l'ingénieur
[Musique]
sur son pyjama Viki Vachon dénonce
l'absolution conditionnelle dont a
bénéficier Simon houle notamment en
raison de sa carrière et de sa bonne
moralité dans un rapport déposé à la
cour dans Radio-Canada obtenu copie son
agent de probation soulignait son
insécurité avec les femmes et une
certaine peur du rejet
mais il l'aurait eu son casier
judiciaire et non lui il est ingénieur
avec sa belle bague puis il y a le droit
d'être là elle a porté plainte à la
police mais comme les gestes auraient
été posés à l'étranger pour porter des
accusations le DPCP devrait procéder à
une analyse juridique laquelle doit être
menée à la lumière de l'ensemble des
circonstances si la preuve suffisante
Simon houle pourrait aussi être accusé
de ne pas avoir respecté les conditions
de sa probation comme avoir une bonne
conduite le ministère public pourrait
demander que le dossier soit renvoyé
devant le juge politique et qu'il
rendent la sentence appropriée
ces nouvelles allégations galvanises des
activistes qui ont manifesté contre le
jugement elle réclame plus d'encadrement
pour éviter les récidives
par rapport à comment on peut faciliter
l'accès et thérapie là parce que
autrement j'ai beaucoup de misères à
l'imaginer que ce genre de situation là
n'est qu'un cas isolé Viki va chaud
pense aux deux victimes connues de Simon
Houlle dont celle pour laquelle il n'a
jamais été accusé je veux que les jeux
j'y repense à deux fois avant de laisser
en liberté un agresseur ici Geneviève
Garon Radio-Canada Montréal